I'm gonna drive without him the hell
with him
hi there I'm Brent Morin star of NBC's
undateable which is all live this season
so please watch it cuz I'm gonna mess up
and right now I'm gonna show you my
youtube playlist not show you I'm gonna
tell you that's stupid Brent I'm just
gonna show you you're gonna see what I
like I watch a lot of NBA stuff Michael
Jordan was my hero growing up so my
first video is the 1996 NBA Finals Game
six
Father's Day championship this is where
Michael Jordan where his father sadly
had been murdered he wouldn't he played
baseball for a little bit and he finally
comes back everybody it's like he can't
come back and he did and then he wins a
championship on Father's Day game six at
home in Chicago with his family there
and loses it second they won he grabbed
the basketball hug the basketball ran to
the locker room sobbing on the ground
Michael Jordan dude I get emotional
online okay I make jokes at the club and
then I get emotional online
[Applause]
my video too is performance at the White
House Gary Clark jr. catfish blues this
guy 28 29 years old a blues guitarist
from Austin Texas monster
here's why I like this when I watch live
videos I like to see the reaction of
other people be like whoa he really
likes that guy
you see Obama just vibe in dude when you
see Michelle vibin then there's a
grandmother I think next to them that's
not into it but as it's that bothered me
she was just staring at the camera
no reaction physically to this fantastic
musician and it took me immediately out
[Music]
third video I like photograph edge here
in 2015 at the global citizens festival
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I think he did such a great job in his
performance but I hate the crowd Glenn
on the phone they don't care about the
cause honestly I don't know what global
citizen is personally I'm not I'm not
one of those people who knows stinks but
get your [ __ ] together okay you're
watching that he's got a guitar he's got
a loop pedal he's wearing flannels and
he's killing
[Music]
the other reason I like this video is
about the four minutes into it for no
reason at all they cut to jay-z and I
sure just watching him he knows they're
watching there's no way he doesn't know
and there was a moment where I felt like
all right add you hamming it up you want
our Jay to like you now at first they're
talking maybe it was something like you
believe this guy and then towards the
end you could tell they're both into it
being like yeah but they're also trying
to be cool and that's terrible
impressions of both of them my next one
is Derrick Rose 2011 2010 MVP award
presentation and speech he is now the
youngest MVP in NBA history
ladies and gentlemen Chicago's very own
Derrick Rose the reason I love this one
because I don't want to say I'm
physically attracted to him but I am
okay and he's also a great ball player
what I love about this speech is he
thinks his brothers for helping them and
he Danks his mother and last but not
least someone think my mom he starts
crying
the brothers start crying she starts
crying I'm been crying
you know I'm five videos in at this
point and I go back and watch this every
time it's about hard work perseverance
how lucky he is
you keep me going every day and I love
you and I appreciate you being in my
life I love you all thank you and I got
to do a tie with this one too cuz
there's two speeches cuz this was the
speech and then Kevin Durant won the MVP
and came out with another one unless my
mom I don't think you know what you did
I gotta be honest you want to build up
to the cry you never want to get the
tears away too fast you know the odds
were stacked against us single parent
with two boys but that last line you're
the real MVP everybody loses it you the
real MVP
I have nowhere he pulls out of his ass
the greatest line that came out of any
Cameron Crowe movie later find out he
didn't write the speech he said I wanted
to speak from the heart now I'm losing
it again so I had to rewatch it to be
like how'd he do it you have the real
MVP I'm doing a three-way it's hi by the
way for this one it's those two speeches
and then Will Smith Fresh Prince of
bel-air why don't he love me man ain't
like imma be sittin up every night
asking my mom when's daddy coming home
you know who needs him he wasn't there
to teach me how to shoot my first basket
but I learned didn't I
hey I got pretty damn good too didn't I
got through my first day without him
right I learned how to drive I learn how
to shave I learned how to fight without
him I had 14 great birthdays without him
he never even sent me a damn card
there's a couple reasons I like this one
it's great to see that in a sitcom
somebody's on a sitcom
I can't wait and hopefully get to do one
of those episodes in my life okay why
just lose it you don't want other reason
I like it Uncle Phil knocking his hat
off when they hug right pushes that hat
out of the way you don't think about
that stuff I do that hat wasn't supposed
to come off he said get out of your hat
wills crying
Uncle Phil hugging him gets me every
time and then that odd panned down for
the father hold the son of the gift you
didn't need it
that's my youtube playlist that's the
kind of stuff I get into and I will only
give you this advice get a good crying
at least once a week have a good sob I'm
Brent Morin thank you it was the
beginning of seeing Will Smith as a
movie star and that's also one of the
reasons that he wanted to leave the show